all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
microbiome in health and wellness
hackathon you have probably heard the
term hackathon before but unless you are
let's say already involved in a tech
industry you're likely wondering what is
a hackathon exactly it sounds so trendy
and exciting but what does it actually
entail A hackathon is often a
competition style event that brings
together individuals to develop new
approaches to solve problems or complete
large projects that require
collaboration and one of the best things
about participating in hackathon is the
opportunity to meet new people who care
about the issue or technology that you
care about whether it's for project
collaboration finding a mentor or even
potential employers hackathons are a
great place to make connections that
could pay dividends in the future and
that is why this November we are
organizing a hackathon on microbiome in
health and wellness to provide students
with a platform to Showcase their
Innovative mindset of problem solving
in this hackathon each student will have
the opportunity to develop a mini
project around the hack upon topic form
a team with with at least two other
students and compete against others for
mentorship support from established
companies and long-term interests from
the business Community the applications
of hackathon are in the fields of
obesity and prostitution nutrition
Innovation and beauty products and
pregnancy in today's webinar we will be
first introducing the participants to
the microbiome and health and wellness
hackathon and provide an overview of
week one workshop on microbiome and
Technology where we will be covering
topics on microbiome sequencing
analytics and bioinformatics and
recommendation system
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based by informatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
as a part of the hackathon students will
have access to the omics logic training
that has been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and due to this fast
growth our team is working with local
and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world this training has been completed
by participants in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infection diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
as a part of the hackathon students will
also have access to the omic storage
resources but how does it help Advance
bioinformatics teaching omic's logic is
important for practical and theoretical
learning of bioinformatics it takes a
combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy permit no matter what
the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is almost logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this also comes with an access to the
Omens logic courses which include
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-ohomics including
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using iron python as well
as cheminformatics and example projects
of different fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work users will be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatics processing
and Analysis of data this platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of the
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multiomics platform
so first of all let us Begin by signing
up on the omics logic blown portal
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the photo looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles this
could be your Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram or kaidi or even Twitter a
brief buyer about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interests the mentors can
view your progress under the activity
tag the courses you are currently
completing will appear under the course
staff finally after the completion of
your course the certificates will appear
under the certificates tab so with that
let us Begin by signing up on the portal
I am sharing the link in the chat box
please click on the link and I'll walk
you through the process behind signing
up on the port
all right
so here is the link
right so for users who do not have an
existing account please click on the
create an account option that you see
here here you will be asked to enter
your name email ID and provide a
password you also have the option to
sign up using any of your social media
accounts which could be Google Facebook
app account GitHub account or even
Twitter with that I'll pause for a
couple of minutes for the participants
to sign up once you have signed up
please put a yes in the chat box so that
I know that we are good to proceed and
if you're facing any technical issues
for signing up on the portal you can
share that in the chat as well and our
team will be happy to help you
so I'm monitoring the chat box
I'm waiting for the 10 plus participants
that we have
all right so we have one response
okay two people
[Music]
if you're having any queries or
technical issues please put them in the
chat we can
we are glad to help you
all right so since I already have an
account on the portal I am going to
click on the login now option so this is
oh this is also applicable for the users
who already have an existing account
so once you sign in
you're able to view the various courses
and example projects that are applicable
here so for example if you're interested
in meta genomics you can simply enter
the keyword here for meta genomics
and you can see the various courses and
example projects that are relevant to
this keyword all right so now click on
the tab that says welcome back with your
email ID
this is the part where you will be able
to update your account so for that click
on the icon that says profile here you
will be able to upload your profile
image and brief brief by about yourself
that could be your education background
research interest the name should be in
appropriate capitalization and as you
can see here I have linked my LinkedIn
account and my ok
and under the activity tab the community
manager and the mentor will be able to
track your learning progress and the
courses that you are currently
completing will be appearing under the
course tab so for instance my interest
right now is in Python course so I'm
completing python course too and once
you upload any of the projects that will
be visible under the project staff and
if you're enrolling for any of the
programs for example I've enrolled in
Precision medicine program it will
appear under the programs tab and once
you complete the courses after
completing the quizzes and all of the
assignment tasks you will be able to
receive the certificates under the
certificate staff so with that if anyone
have any queries regarding signing up or
are chasing any technical issues please
put that in the chat and I will be able
to
guide you
otherwise
we're good to go and now I would like to
pass on the stage to Mr Elia brotsky CEO
of find biotech to give an overview of
the hackathon
so over G
thank you uh Oregon that was a great
introduction
um and uh welcome everyone to this
webinar I will briefly speak about what
is
um what this hackathon is about why we
chose to focus on the microbiome what
kinds of opportunities I see for
students and researchers as well as
companies that might want to participate
so let's start by briefly talking about
why microbiome
um I have some stats here on the slide
um that basically show that startups
that Focus just on the gut microbiome
for health Clues raised over 1 billion
in VC funding over the past five years
it's 2020 and before
so what we see is a tremendous interest
in the space from The Venture Capital
Community and that just gives you a
perspective
on the overall interest in how
microbiome can be involved in health
disease and wellness now we're not going
to focus on disease here but we are
going to talk about Wellness
um so as you can see it's a hugely
growing uh field and Industry you can
see that there are a lot of patent
applications that are being applied for
and this has grown
um almost I would say exponentially uh
since the
2010-2011. and down here you can see how
this interest has a practical Direction
so we're not just interested in the
microbiome the basic science of the
microbiome how it works but we're
actually seeing a lot of interest in
trying to apply
these insights and translate them into
some kind of a product or an
intervention so what we decided to do is
kind of take a look at data-driven
Innovation and what we want to provide
uh the community the broader Community
with are data sets that describe real
world studies and experiments uh
intuitive Solutions so you can see what
kinds of things are people building and
what are they doing with this kind of
data and then explain how such data
could be analyzed visualized and
presented in a meaningful way so for
those students and faculty who are
interested we think that this is an
opportunity to innovate solve and
connect innovate by being creative open
and collaborate with others you can come
at these existing solutions that are
being addressed by others with an out of
the box thinking approach you can really
do something novel you will also see
that this is an opportunity to showcase
how you can solve complex problems and
so for a lot of students this is a way
to Showcase their abilities stand out
from the crowd uh you know really kind
of apply what you have learned what you
know to a new challenge and connecting
is an important factor here as well so
by working with people who are from uh
the business Community from the research
Community from the computer science
Community you will see that this
interdisciplinary aspect is a huge
component of innovation and we hope that
this hackathon could be an opportunity
for you to do just that now this is
going to be a virtual event so you don't
have to be physically at any single
location you can participate from India
from Africa from Brazil from the US
anywhere in the world really and I think
the benefit of that is because we can
see that these Trends are going to
continue and grow in the future so not
only have we seen work being disrupted
Innovation and collaboration has been
disrupted as well and I think that at
one side kind of disrupts the way things
have been done but it also provides
extreme New Opportunities so if you're
in India you might be thinking yes this
investment might be happening in the U.S
how can I actually be involved but the
truth is that more and more Venture
Capital firms in the U.S are looking
outside of the U.S to find innovation in
the U.S you might be thinking well how
do I do something differently from the
way that it's done here right and this
is an opportunity to find people who
might have completely different ideas
different audiences different targets
uh ultimately this is an opportunity to
build and compete and by building is
very different than doing research right
so we've seen a lot of uh interest in
research problems that result in
academic Publications maybe this is
intellectual property but it is often
not a product and so what we hope to see
out of this event are more ideas that
have practical applications or at least
a direction at that kind of a solution
what kinds of topics are we going to
cover
we're going to focus here on three
different topics that are all extremely
relevant popular and interesting in the
domain of microbiome the first one this
is probably something that the majority
of the people know about and is the most
obvious one is the Obesity and Precision
Nutrition and what that means is that
the gut microbiome has been studied
enough to show that there's a critical
connection between different types of
foods and Lifestyles with obesity and
Precision Nutrition this also has to do
with food being a functional medicine
so that means that some conditions even
though they are early on can become
chronic and very complicated to treat
with drugs with surgery
um you know with these severe
interventions but at an earlier stage
they could really be prevented with
dieting with different types of
functional foods that help the
microbiome be restored and function
properly
the second may be a little bit less
known field of application for the
microbiome is skin aging and beauty and
we'll actually have an innovator herself
and a startup founder herself but also a
researcher speak about what are some of
those Innovative and cutting-edge
applications of the microbiome to the
field of beauty and aging and then the
final one is something that all of us
have gone through in some way and this
is pregnancy and femtech so a lot of the
microbiome Studies have pointed to
different associations between uh you
know different types of pregnancy that
has healthy or more risky outcomes and
so this is a field that definitely has a
lot of impact as well so for obesity and
nutrition we see that the gut microbiome
has been studied for associations
between diet and the microbiome healthy
weight loss risk of diabetes
personalized nutrition plans
recommendations on pre and probiotics as
well as different types of sensitivities
and you can see that there are a lot of
clinical trials which means that there's
a lot of data sets that are available to
test and identify interesting insights
from these data sets so we'll introduce
those data sets and we'll also talk
about some of the industry challenges
now in the field of the gut microbiome
the obvious challenge is that there are
some established companies that come out
with very similar tests at pricing that
varies between approximately 60 and 200
or more than 200 they use different
techniques
and they provide different types of
insights but all of them claim to be the
best the most advanced the most
comprehensive so the question is which
one is the best the you know most
comprehensive the most insightful and
what are some of those use cases that
could be turned into Innovation that
could kind of change the way that things
are done today the skin and microbiome
uh has a lot of applications from rashes
to acne to wrinkles blemishes longevity
and aging and so since more and more
people are aware of how their skin looks
and what they do to make it look better
this has become already an opportunity
for people to develop new products and
those new products include things you
can buy on Amazon like new biome is a a
type of a company that produces a lotion
that is matching your skin microbiome so
really interesting direct applications
that are already being done in the
industry now the question is how do
these things work and what are some
opportunities to introduce new ideas
into this space
now in the field of femtech there's also
a lot of studies going on for healthy
childbirth immunity and conception
antibiotics diet and activity
reproductive health and there are
already these products being sold on the
market so I think that there's a lot of
interesting associations even in things
like the child's psychology over the
years being influenced by childbirth and
you know the mother's microbiome so
there's a lot of interesting um
ideas here
um and I think that this would be an
opportunity to both learn about what
those things are and try to develop some
Innovative uh product now we are going
to uh try to prepare everyone to focus
on real problems and real solutions that
are possible that are realistic and for
that we're going to bring in experts to
speak about different types of
sequencing Technologies as I mentioned
curated data repositories where you can
actually find some of these studies and
do something with them
people that specialize in business
analysis and framing the problem in
business terms as well as user
experience how do you not only produce
an example but actually turn that into
an experience that somebody can use why
sequencing Technologies well sequencing
technologies have been one of the main
drivers of cost accessibility
and Detail in this field and so uh you
know companies like Illumina and Oxford
nanoport have developed very different
approaches But ultimately now we are in
a race to the bottom of the pricing
scale right so new technologies are
becoming much more useful and affordable
and that is driving accessibility for
these types of Innovations now for all
of these different types of sequencing
there are still challenges associated
with data analysis so we will talk about
how these data are analyzed and these
include multiple all types of omics data
including intuitive and informative
analysis types and that's really where
bioinformatics and multi-omics data
analysis comes in so we'll talk about
how these types of data are analyzed and
integrated
now after we talk about just in general
what is the logic for this kind of
analysis will actually make sure that
everyone has access to easy to use tools
that they can produce insights quickly
and we'll make sure that you have access
to our TBI info platform with these
different types of pipelines that are
available on there already
now in addition to that we'll talk about
non-omix data where to produce a product
you actually have to focus on finding
associations between omics and non-omix
data such as maybe different types of
you know lifestyle and activity tracking
devices
this is an important topic and we'll
kind of introduce you to how that could
be done and what are some of the
companies that are doing this already
now when we think about this we're going
to look at the business aspect as well
and that means understanding these
industry trends that we just spoke about
but also looking at customers and their
kind of segments or portions of the
customers that might be the best to
focus on and for that we will bring in
investors that will actually speak about
what is working and what is not working
in this microbiome uh you know
Innovative space that startups are
competing for funding it and they will
talk about some previous Investments
that have been made and whether those
have been successful unsuccessful and in
which way now as I mentioned we're not
going to be the only ones talking we're
actually going to bring in uh experts in
the field that have been working for
decades from different aspects including
startup Founders people that specialize
in sequencing Technologies investors
existing companies that kind of deal in
this space
as well as some researchers uh that are
exploring different opportunities with
microbiome data as well now primarily
this event is going to be focused on our
partnering universities and that's why
we are working to um kind of streamline
the pipeline and the main challenge here
is preparing students to be ready to
address some of these uh interesting
topics and challenges early on right so
we don't want to spend a lot of time on
the basics we want to jump in to the
real opportunities that are there now we
have over 10 000 members in this
partnership program and we would love to
see your organization join here as well
the community that we've established has
grown tremendously and so we are really
excited to see a lot of interest in the
space but we also see the need to
continue and train people to be able to
use omics data both for basic and
translational research so with that that
I will pass it on to Dr raghavendran Who
will speak about
um how this is actually going to work
thank you Elia let me find ways to share
my stream and set up my
presentation
foreign
I'm working as a bioinformatics mentor
with mind biotech and I welcome all of
you to this portion of the webinar to
introduce you to uh to this um hackathon
and let's discuss some Basics about uh
in this in this position we will discuss
some Basics about
um
what is microbiome and what are some of
the sequencing technologies that relate
homage data analysis with microbiome and
what is the approach in bioinformatics
analysis methods towards understanding
the association of microbial population
with the disease and we discussed this
from the point of view or from the
popular Publications and popular
research reviews so this will actually
give you necessary tools and some idea
and production and this will prepare you
for
for participating in this hackathon that
focuses on microbiome in health and
wellness so let's jump in let's start by
reviewing a little bit of history of
microbiology so where the study of
microorganisms leads to the creation of
tools and approaches that are still used
today to continue and to uncover the
wheel of world which we do not see but
yet has such a profound effect on
everything that is around us it's this
all started with
for example microscopes that helps us
observe the or that actually help us
observe the first bacteria means 16 1673
so but today we have microscopes that
can enlarge from
50 to 300 times the um the size of the
first observation of bacteria that was
made long long time ago so as the
resolution of this microscopes in
improved more and more representatives
of this Unseen World have been
discovered today the microscopes that we
are using are tremendously powerful and
it allows us to see smaller and smaller
elements that reveal how the world of
microorganisms functions on every
imaginable surface so in this example
for example in this image we can see a
super high resolution image of
bacteriophages that are green in color
attacking the bacteria that is E coli
that is blue in color so we have
Advanced to such a level of
high resolution and this actually
um made us Define microbiology not only
by the organisms that the the research
study so that there's field studies but
also by the tools that are used to study
them and these tools as we already
discussed has evolved to allow us to
study and categorize microorganisms
specifically and the technology for
bacterial culturing coupled with the
technique to stain bacteria has
historically improved our ability to
isolate to classify and to determine
whether a bacteria is a cause of human
disease or even select appropriate
treatment for handling that pathogenic
entity
why are we interested in studying the
microorganisms generally so the
connection between disease and
microorganisms has been well established
since the 1800s and these studies
actually provide uh
important information about bacterial
function in isolation however as more
and more studies came
um came through it became apparent that
most microorganisms live in a complex
communities and many members of which
are impossible to culture in isolation
and today we know that microorganisms
are the microbiota that make up the for
example human microbiome are not just
unicellular organisms living in
isolation alongside each other but
instead they are highly regulated highly
structured and highly functionally
organized communities
so let's take a human skin as an example
right bacteria are we know that bacteria
are able to grow other to almost every
surface uh forming architecturally
complex communities that are that we
call or that are termed as biofuels the
stability of these biofilms or the
communities is fascinating as many of us
probably know from trying to battle
um common skin conditions such as dry
skin acne and eczema for example so
forming these distinct communities these
microorganisms are interconnected and
are determined to maintain their
community's stability and these bacteria
for example within the community or from
this biofilm can communicate with each
other by producing detecting and
responding to small signal molecules in
a process called Quorum sensor right
this process or this Quorum sensing
activities in these communities are also
involved not only in communication but
also in in the vigilance of the
pathogenic bacteria are in response to
for example external stimuli or also in
controlling the
host defenses and in responding to
antimicrobial agent Etc so inside such
Community or inside each Community there
is a balance of bacteria fungi and
viruses that controls the species
abundance and the activity oh
so this balance is very absolutely
necessary and very important for our
understanding of the association of this
microbial Community with not only with
diseases but also with health and
wellness and general well-being of our
ourselves so microbes inhabit just about
every part of the human body
not only on the skin right for example
we already saw some examples of microbes
living on the skin and we we definitely
see microbes living in the gut and up in
the nose and gastroenteric pathway
everywhere the microbes or the diversity
of these organisms that inhibit various
human bodies and are estimated to make
up more than half of people's cells
right and this diversity is extremely
critical to human health right and most
of the time these microorganisms that
live in harmony with our with their
human host provides extremely important
functions that are essential for human
survival for example from enabling the
work of the immune system to
underpinning brain function the
microbiome has been linked to nearly
every health condition that one can find
the association so today health related
interventions and well-being related
interventions seek to manipulate the
population of these microbial diversity
or
the diversity of this microbial
population rather through products such
as probiotics through drugs through
therapies through foods and through
wellness products and etc etc some of
which Ilya already had introduced you
so one such example in this Association
is detailed in this review right this
review focuses on the microbial
diversity in the gut altering the
responses in the diversity observed in
the skin right there for example this
image actually shows the inflammatory
and microbial influences between the gut
and skin for a healthy state in the left
and for the dysbiotic state or
non-healthy state in the right and they
are compared in detail in this review so
I will shortly summarize it the
dysbiotic state is characterized
generally by by an impact gut bacteria
gut barrier for example this impact gut
bacteria barrier results in the
imbalance in gut microbiome and this gut
microbiome can be for example
ah can also result in reduced mucous
layer formation or reduced uh you know
immunoglobulin secretion or this again
can promote barrier disruption this can
actually create imbalance in the
intestinal permeation into the
bloodstream and also can generally cause
gut inflammation or this dysbiotic state
can also be characterized by impaired
skin barrier right this generally result
in imbalance in the skin microbiome and
this reduces for example human and
antimic microbial antimicrobial peptide
production this promotes skin rashes
this promote lesions skin inflammation
and Etc other conditions this this
biosis between the gut and skin are
actually connected through a balance
between or balance in the helper T cells
or t lymphocytes and in this this biosis
or in this imbalance there this balance
is actually skewed uh towards uh this
balance is actually extremely skewed
where
we can we can or this review actually
focuses on identifying whether this qns
results from the gut dysbiosis are from
the skin dysbiosis so if you want to
check uh
if you want to read little bit more
about this review let me paste the
publication's link
if I can get it
in the chat box
yeah I got it
so please go through this publication if
you are interested in this is this is an
excellent review uh that will open your
eyes to several different uh
associations and that can be very very
helpful in general
so
moving on the imbalance as we saw in the
in one such example for example uh gut
microbial diversity is related to many
modulations or many infectious diseases
and and their pathogenesis for example
many more studies actually uses uh
um the human microbiome project data for
the following Association right the role
of gut microbiome has been Associated to
Crohn's diseases it is generally found
associated with ulcer or esophagal
cancer right the role of skin microbiome
is is associated or is generally related
to psoriasis atopic dermatitis and even
sometimes immunodeficiencies and
sometimes uh in in some of the
Publications the role of urogenital
microbiome is related to reproductive
complications right and really also
focused on the child birth right and
several Publications and research
focuses on understanding the
understanding number of childhood
disorders from gut microbial population
right including for example pediatric
abdominal pain it also includes
intestinal inflammations and also
sometimes a severe condition in which
premature infants actually die due to
the fact that the intestine actually
dies inside there so these are all some
of the interesting starting points that
you can explore
so what happens is these researchers and
these studies actually fuel these
exponential increase in the microbial
data or microbiome data that has that
are available in publicly available
resources are repositories and these
were significantly Advanced through
major initiatives in for example
um in the metagenomics of human
intestinal tract or in subsequent human
microbiome project now we have Earth
microbiome project and a lot of these
huge studies that have been made
possible through advancements in
metagenomic sequencing right so the
result of this is that not only skin and
gut which are well known to be a carrier
of microbial diverse microbial
population
lungs and even brain microbiota are
starting to be characterized and each
new project represents extremely vast
opportunities and challenges to
determine which microorganisms play key
role in the development of certain
environmental conditions necessary for
healthy functioning of the human organs
or
which which subset of those microorganic
organisms can be harmful to those human
organisms themselves right
so this actually
um
as we know can contribute to critical uh
uh sorry this actually can expand our
understanding of uh of studying these
endogenous human microbial communities
that can contribute to critical
metabolic and physiological and
immunological functions that include
maturation of the immune system that
includes for example energy generation
metabolic regulation fat storage and
skin maintenance and etc etc right you
can explore a lot of these things in in
this program
in this hackathon so so far we have been
discussing about the data or microbial
data geometogenomics data microbial
population so what's in store for the
bioinformatization right for the
bioinformatization's perspective from
the bioinformaticians perspective
metagenomics is the genomic analysis of
microbial DNA from environmental
communities right the tools that will
enable us to perform this metagenomics
analysis will actually help us
understand the population of this
microbial community that were previously
unculturable or that were previously
unexplorable right and this ability to
identify microbes without an a priority
knowledge of what the sample contains is
opening new doors in disciplines not
only related to for example disease
biology but also generally expands the
horizons of microbiology biology
environmental Sciences biomedical
research assets right and sequencing
based examinations of metagenomes has
actually become a powerful tool for
generating a novel hypothesis based on
the microbial population and um
Community microbial Community uh
population analysis not my
animation is running so sorry about that
yeah
so unlike other omics metagenomics does
not study a single organism right but a
whole community at once this is a
snapshot of collection of organisms
directly in their natural environment
right since the genomes are so diverse
this is typically accomplished or
carried out by sequencing a specific
marker portion of the genome instead of
all the genomic material present in the
given sample and how are these done many
of these processes are done using Next
Generation sequencing that focuses
either on sequencing sometimes
sequencing the whole genome or
transcriptome of the microbial
population or most of the time a popular
approach is to select a portion or such
a gene of these bacteria or the portions
of the genes that are that are in the
variable sections right
we will discuss this in a little bit
while yeah so these are these can be
shortly divided or roughly divided into
categorized into a shotgun metagenomics
or meta transcriptomics approaches and
16s amplicon based approaches right the
16 is amplicon sequencing is is actually
a recently developed it's not now recent
it's very well developed now technique
that is widely used to study microbiome
directly in its environment as we
already discussed right this approach or
this sequencing approach focuses not on
the whole or not on sequencing the whole
genome of the organism or of the
bacterial Community but it focuses on
16s or 18s ribosomal rrna that can be
Amplified using several amplification
methods this Gene cyclinous Gene
contains hyper variable regions that can
provide species specific signature that
are useful for back material taxonomical
identification
and this identification can be carried
out from a diverse set of these species
specific signature sequences to account
for the diversity of such sequences they
are usually combined into operational
taxonomy and neonates or otus which can
be used to classify groups of closely
related individuals and otus are
actually formed from groups of these
genomic sequences that represent a
cluster or a phylogenetic clay that has
um that are closely related and that has
meaningful abundance in our sample
so by far the most common type of
clustering method for studying microbial
studies has been uh this operational
taxonomic units right this this works by
identifying clusters of closely related
sequences uh with a fixed identity cut
off however different regions or
different sequences vary in their uh
vary in their for example uh sequence
identity percentage and sometimes
phylogenetically related facts are sharp
and less predictable identity percentage
this is a limitation in the study or in
other words this 97 percentage that one
uses to Cluster these sequences into
otus might not cover all of the um
sequences diversity or might also
include some of the closely related
species to address these limitations in
recent years a denoising method has been
introduced through several different
popular algorithm as an alternative
clustering method this algorithm
actually uses probabilistic method to
predict uh actual sequencing errors
which are noise before forming clusters
and hence this clustering method is
termed as amplicon sequence variance and
this is based on sequence probability
rather than sequence identity and this
results in a fewer but self-consistent
custom clusters that have been
thoroughly validated to have more
acceptable Precision in many different
Publications
so for example based on mapping of these
specific regions that are Amplified from
let's say 16s RNA G
in the bacterial ribosome these otus are
asvs can be assigned to belong to
particular taxonomic classes of bacteria
and this will actually help us
for example calculate the abundance of
each one of those material family or
phyla in the community and each
Community can be studied by comparing
with the others between similar
conditions or different conditions or
between different individuals or between
um between different state of these
individuals for example healthy and
obese or
are generally yeah people with uh
autoimmune diseases or not
for example so these analysis will
actually include in-depth understanding
of data preparation reference databases
and analytical approaches to uh for
example to
formulate hypothesis or to answer
specific questions based on what we are
actually understanding or what we are
actually uh
identifying from these taxonomical
classification so importantly this
sequencing data for example will
represent only one type of microbial
omics which are
becoming many more in sorry about that
yeah this sequencing data will actually
represent uh this meta genomics uh
abundance classification which will help
us in as we already discussed in
quantifying the abundance levels of
different phyla or genus or species
level classification of bacteria in the
sample so this is usually done by
annotating or mapping these otus or ASP
sequences to a reference database and
these reference database can actually
include ribosomal database project or
repository such as green genes or the
silver database so these databases
contain taxonomic information for the
domains of bacteria archaea Eukarya
based on primarily
uh based primarily on the phylogenesis
phylo genetic information or Philo uh
phylogenes that are built from the small
subunit rrnas are 16s rrna for the
prokaryotes and 18s rrna for the
eukaryotes so we can use this for
example the silver database to identify
and to understand the taxonomical
distribution of our portals
so what is the next step in this
bioinformatics approach towards studying
microbial abundance right so many
questions about the role of microbial
members or microbial members and
communities are now being answered using
um these next Generation sequence in
genomic data that we can generate and
this also can be done or this in in
comparison or in complementary
approaches such as mass spectrometry
approaches for proteomics and
metabolomics uh data generation will can
also be used to study this or related
questions so the next phase of this
microbial research actually lies in the
ability to integrate these multi-ohomics
data sets to combine not only the Next
Generation genomic or metagenomic data
they they can also integrate the Mass
Effect data or they can also integrate
the structural data with phenotypical
information about the overall changes in
the community in their natural
environment so this is where the next
few years or next few approaches of
biomedical research in metagenomics and
microbial population research is taking
you so
so
as we have discussed about uh the
history of microbiology the emergence of
sequencing Technologies and how this
data can be used to study for example
abundance microbial abundance in the
samples so let me uh show you or let me
share with you some of the additional
resources that you can rely from the
learn omics logic portal to study these
topics in Greater detail and this will
also include practical analysis tools
that you can gain experience to in
handling such debt assets right
see
what Gap now it's so we have courses on
metagenomics and we have example
projects that take for example that
um
[Music]
include data from popular Publications
and explores their effects or explores
the
um
explores the data for their association
with with what has been studied or with
some novel associations that you can
find from existing Publications for
example in Project 19 project 19 takes
the
red syndrome data red syndrome microbial
microbial population that is estimated
for children with red syndrome and for
healthy individuals and finds the
dysbiosis and relates that displays is
generally with the dyspliosis that is
characterized uh symbiosis and this
biosis that is characterized after
subjecting this
subjecting the patients and population
to variety of different anti anti
bacterial or antibiotic and treatments
so that's an excellent project for
example to integrate information from
more than one source of publication and
we have several other projects such as
projects that focuses on human
microbiome data and a project that
focuses on model system like a mouse
model system so which will which we will
shortly discuss
so let's talk a little bit about the
approaches that you will be introduced
to and throughout this course you will
be given access and directions to the
server T bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing and for
analyzing these meta genomics data this
platform includes demo pipelines and
this also includes analysis approaches
to run metagenomics bioinformatics
pipeline different stages of this
analysis are performed on different what
happened yeah different stages of this
analysis are performed on different
sections of this multiomics platform so
you can explore not only on this
metagenomics area but also the other
ones when you are interested to do
so the interface of This Server will
enable you to quickly build logical
graphs of analysis methods and sequence
pipelines to understand each steps and
their significance in their in this
analysis for for for interested people
they implemented pipeline
can be accessed using the demo pipeline
that I will show you how to do that so
let's quickly go through for example uh
a demo pipeline of a project that we
will definitely get our hands on in this
program so this project is a practical
example
of understanding the role of high fat
diet on Obesity right so this is the
project number 13 in the learn omics
logic portal so
when you have if you have uh if you have
the subscription or when you have when
you get your subscription you can
um you can get uh introduced to this
project this is an extremely interesting
project where okay what happened
yeah so where the aim of the study is to
test the hypothesis that the Obesity
Associated microbiome undermines
Behavior even in the absence of obesity
uh
okay something happened
can you see my screen still I'm getting
screen not shared yes so we're able to
see the screen okay sorry thank you yeah
I'm getting screen is not shut okay okay
let's see so for example in this study
generally uh the mouse will actually
receive
um the microbial population that has
been generated or that has been
extracted from mouse that are fed with
normal diet and mouse that are fed with
high fat diet and we will see
associations of the changes in these
microbe in this mouse and their behavior
and how the um
um abundance levels of these microbial
population addresses uh relates to the
dietary supplements and that are that we
can associate with the uh the respective
mouse let's uh let me reshare my screen
again to take you to uh the demo
pipeline that I was talking to you about
contribution
okay I got it I think
okay can you see my screen or it's still
sharing
um
no it's not shedding though yeah it's
not shutting now I also got this where
is this
okay I think you should be able to see
can you see my screen can you confirm
what are you actually yeah
uh we're able to see T bioinfo areas for
areas of analysis perfect thank you very
much so this is a project that I was
talking to you about this project is an
excellent starting point where uh the
use of the model system will actually
ease you into the metagenomics analysis
where we do not see complications due to
the sample diversity or for example
which you will generally observe when
you acquire sample from human systems or
real life human system so this this is
an excellent project to start with and
in this project after introducing you to
what this study is about and what is the
background and how are we going to set
up a hypothesis to study their
Association then we have a practical
Hands-On of Performing these 16s
amplicon sequencing analysis in the
turbo by info platform so this is
explained to you in lesson number five
that we will go through using the tbio
info platform server so in this server
page if you come down scroll down in the
metagenomics uh under the metagenomics
section with amplicon 16s and 18s
analysis then you can drop it down to
access the demo pipeline that is ciao
versus hfd so if you have access or if
you have uh registration uh credentials
to server you can access this demo
python we have prepared this demo
pipeline for you to get a test or get an
understanding of how to set up this
analysis pipeline for the data or for
the input files that we have already
uploaded to the
to this necessary pipeline analysis so
anybody who has
login credentials to This Server can
access this demo pipeline irrespective
of their subscription status
so what do you do you start
so where do you go next is highlighted
with the yellow highlights and in each
and every one of these steps what has
been done is actually
um
described here in brief so we perform
some pre-processing about data
so interested people can read through
this to what's been actually done and
for example in this will have links to
their respective methods and
citations for the respective methods and
Publications that talk about those
analysis
foreign
for possible options or possible
sequence analysis or analysis
approaches that you can add next so here
to guide you through these analysis
methods only the next step is
highlighted so in true when you are
going to input your data you will be
presented with multitude of different
Pathways that one can take so you have
to build the analysis pipeline depending
upon the kind of question that you are
asking and the data that we are using
for analysis methods
so once this is done
and then once the end is done you will
get
um access to all the output files that
includes all the plots all the tables
and Etc and also accessible
um
interactive plots that you will get your
hand sample right you get abundance plot
and you'll get relative abundance upon
where you can understand for example if
you check the abundance plot you will
see that
this bacterial phyla or I think this is
grouped by bacterial I hope it is Tyler
I forgot so um
Rick and Lac right if I can produce
correctly pronounce correctly right it
looks like they these Rick analysis he
has a different abundance level for
different sample types
so these three this sample has a lot of
them and this sample has a very small uh
quantity and this sample has even more
higher quantity so just plotting this uh
in their absolute value is not very
informative so when we use the
proportional abundance plot then we can
clearly see the pattern that um in
proportion to the total number of
abundance that we observe for that
particular sample and these three sample
have a very comparable amount of these
specific species while these three
samples have a lower abundance level of
this species so this is how we can
interpret the data and more on this
level of interpretation and even more
methods of interpretation and usefulness
of this uh tool we also have an
interactive
um
uh uh option which is not loading right
now but when you get your access to This
Server you will see that loaded up here
which is a dashboard that you can change
the parameters that govern uh these uh
abundance calculation for example if I
want to change it from phyla level to
species level that you can do it there
and if I want to change it from species
level to genius level to see this
grouping I can quickly change it there
without running this analysis all over
again so this and also uh
more Downstream analysis on on for
example platforms for those who are
interested on platforms like in R and R
and python are actually given in this
lesson you can definitely check it out
so with that I want to pass the stage
back to Spurs I think
yes uh now we can pass on to Spanish for
the hackathon event details such as
registration process and so on so over
to you
I'm a spouse
I'm so sorry yeah so I was unable to
unmute myself uh and now I like can you
hear me I am audible yes you're audible
perfect so thank you uh Dr Argo engine
uh for the wonderful explanation and I
quickly uh make you through like tell
you all about the registration part of
hackathon so I'll just share my screen
uh give me a second
foreign
[Music]
could you please confirm SRI body if my
screen is visible yes we can see the
hackathon language yes
so uh this is the landing page of
hackathon and I'll share the link uh
with you all in the chat box itself so
after the
okay
so this is something else sorry uh so
this is the landing page I'll share the
link in the chat box itself so that
after the meet you can go through by
yourself and see what exactly we are
including in the hackathon what kind of
workshops we are doing before uh in uh
Workshop before actually
uh like
going into the hackathon ETC so there
are
like the first three weeks are devoted
to different kind of Workshop so this
particular webinar was devoted to tell
you to brief you to give you an insight
about the week one Workshop which will
be starting from November 1. so it was
uh related to microbiome and Technology
we covered here microbiome sequencing
analyticals and bioinformatics and
recommendation system and how you can
leverage a table info server and other
resources on a learn portal and get more
into and learn more about a microbiome
sequencing metagenomic sequencing Etc so
the next webinar uh is next week and
we'll be uh inviting you and we'll be
sending your calendar invite and
invitation mail regarding the week two
regarding the second webinar which will
be devoted to the human microbm and
we'll be telling you and giving you an
Insight of what we'll be including in
the second week of the workshop here and
same goes for the week three Workshop
now moving further so these are some of
the um like export commercial and
academic experts will be there in those
workshops and they'll be guiding you
throughout uh the hackathon what you
need to do so as to uh so that you can
make a kind of a MVP and present it
further now moving further to the
registration cost for the hackathon so
there are three registration costs for
the hackathon depending upon uh like
your participation so for an individual
student as we are a us-based company in
the beginning itself SRI gauri explained
that we are a us-based company so the
pricing is in dollars
uh so for the individual student who
needs like who is willing to participate
for the hackathon the registration cost
is dollar hundred for a group of
students so by a group of students we
mean that four to five students the
registration cost is a dollar 300 and uh
for the partner University so here
partner University means those
universities uh with whom we have
collaborated with whom we have signed a
mou so the costing is dollar 100. now we
have provided the party University with
a uh 65 percent of discount uh to those
universities who are like partnered with
us and collaborated with us now if
you'll move further you will see three
tabs or three buttons uh these three
buttons are obviously for these three
different registrations one is for
individual student payment Gateway check
out the other is for group students for
three to four then the third is for
payment University
uh partner University payment Gateway
checkout so those who are either from a
partner University or a group of
students from any other university or an
individual student can accordingly
choose the payment Gateway and they can
directly click on this button and it
will be redirected to the payment page
so they can fill out the credentials
like the details the payment information
and they can
um
submit from here on and uh like we'll
get the submission and we'll be sending
you the further details accordingly that
about the November 1 the week one
Workshop then the second week two
workshops in the third week uh three uh
week three workshop and the finally
November 23rd to 28th where we will be
uh doing the presentation of the minimal
value product which you have created
your team has created together so uh
this was about the registration uh and
the cost of the hackathon obviously in
this particular course we will be
providing you with some resources we'll
be providing you the access on our loan
portal uh the access on RT bioinfo
server and many other resources so um
this was all about the registration cost
for the hackathon uh for now and if
anyone is having any kind of doubt
regarding the registration the cost or
the grouping of the students also so uh
please feel free to Ping in the chat box
itself and uh I'll be there to answer
your queries thank you
uh yes so we have a query from Terra
that is can we join a group
yeah yeah so definitely you can join us
group so here it is what like we have
mentioned so in a group there could be
three to four students and the cost is
dollar 300 for them so the students can
be a mix of a mix and match uh like uh
fields or domains a student can be of of
a genomics background and a computer
science or a MBA or whosoever like who's
having expertise in these all Fields can
they all can group together and uh like
participate in hackathon and come up
with the MVP so surely we can you can
join a group
uh so Stephen is asking by a week how
many hours should one at least dedicate
for the course per week
uh so it depends upon uh you Stephen so
we'll be like we'll be providing you
with a card like there will be life uh
kind of sessions also where we'll be
inviting the ex commercial and academic
experts from uh different domains and
areas uh so there will be some live
sessions we will be also providing you
with some kind of data and that would be
asynchronous so we'll be mailing you out
with online Associated resources and you
can according to your type availability
and visibility you can go through with
that resources and uh complete so it
totally depends upon you maybe two hours
a day or it depends upon you so
all right so
thank you so much so do we have any
further queries
if so please put them in the chat box
otherwise you could also reach out to
sparsh Via the email ID that I've shared
in the chat box you can also reach out
to her via her contact number which is
also active on WhatsApp so with that
thank you all for joining today's
webinar I hope to see you all all right
so we have another query so up to how
long will the server be accessible
so uh for uh one month we'll be
providing you with the access of the
server
and Sarah is asking is there any
WhatsApp group as well
um so yes Sarah there is a WhatsApp
group like we have a bioinformatics
community called psyomics we have a club
and we on daily basis update there about
our workshops about our webinars or what
we are conducting next so uh what I'll
be doing is
um
like I'll be sharing the video recording
at this particular session and I'll be
including in the mail itself the
WhatsApp link so you can uh you can see
in that particular mail and you can join
from there as well or if oh just be or
any other group member is here available
they can share the link of WhatsApp
group that would be great
otherwise I'll mail you
ah yes so or just we will be sharing the
link to the WhatsApp group so everyone
interested can join so do we have any
further queries in the meantime
foreign
registration or
the team participation if so please put
them in the chat we'll be happy to help
you
all right like uh sparsh had mentioned
all right okay thank you so much
so we have another webinar in next week
so we'll be mailing out the details of
that as well it will be about the
workshop 2 of the hackathon so I hope to
see you all for that webinar as well and
I hope to see you all participating in
the hackathon so I would highly urge all
of you to make the post out of such a
wonderful opportunity
uh Stephen is asking is this recording
going to be shared yes it will be shared
to you via your email
thank you very much Stephen
all right so urgency has shared the link
to the WhatsApp group as well so those
of you who are interested to know more
about the ban fanatic opportunities and
get up-to-date news about bioinformatics
happenings then you can join the group
so with that thank you everyone for
joining today's webinar I hope to see
you all next week as well and with that
thank you everyone have a great day
thank you